PROFESSOR: There's other kinds
of bogus proofs that come up.
Let's just run through
this one quickly.
Here's a fact that you
about, roots of polynomials.
Every polynomial has
two roots, at least
over the complex
numbers, over c.
And how do you prove that?
Well, you just write down
the formulas for the roots.
You know the quadratic formula.
One root is a minus b
plus this square root
of this quantity of 2a.
And the other root is minus
b minus this square root
of b squared minus 4ac over 2a.
And that's the
end for the proof.
You can just plug-in
this formula for r1
for x into this
polynomial and it
would simplify to
be equal to 0, which
shows that this is a root.
You could plug that one
into this formula for x
and simplify algebraically
and discover it was 0,
proving that r2 is a root.
We've just proved that every
polynomial has two roots.
Well, that's not true.
We haven't proved it.
This is a proof by
calculation that has problems.
What's the problem? well let's
look at a counter example.
What about the polynomial
0x squared plus 0x plus 1?
It doesn't have any roots.
It's just a constant 1 which
never crosses the origin.
So it's got no roots.
What about 0x squared
plus 1x plus 1?
Well that's 45 degree
line, the y equals x line,
and it only crosses
the origin once.
It has only one root.
What happened to the
two formulas, r1 and r2?
And the answer
was, in this case,
we had to divide by 0 error.
If you look at that
formula, there's a quotient,
there's a denominator of 2a.
Divide by 0 and these
formulas don't work right.
They aren't the roots.
And so implicitly, in
order to have two roots,
we need to assume that the
denominator, a, the leading
coefficient of the
polynomial is not 0.
So that fixes those two bugs.
Is that all?
Well, no, because look
at this polynomial.
1x squared plus 0x
plus 0 has one root.
The only possible
root of this is 0.
Because if you look
at this, the only way
to get 1 times something
plus 0 to equals 0
is if the something is 0.
So there's only one root.
And what's going on here?
Well, what's happened is that
in this case, the two formulas,
r1 and r2, which were
different formulas, evaluate
to the same thing when b
is 0 and c is 0 and a is 1.
And that's why they look
like different formulas
but they evaluate to the same
thing so there's only one root.
The fix to that is to
require the quantity
by which the two
root formulas, r1
and r2 differ to be non-zero.
And that's the quantity that we
were taking the square root of,
the discriminant it's called.
b squared minus 4ac needs
to be 0 and then r1
and r2 will differ
and we will get the two roots.
Now, there's still
a complication.
It sounds like
we've now verified
that indeed our
proof by calculation
is correct now that we've
put in these qualifiers,
that a is positive
and d is non-zero.
But what happens if d is
non-zero but negative?
It's an interesting
complication.
And let's look at the
formula, x squared plus 1,
where b squared minus 4ac
is going to be minus 3.
And that will turn out
to have two roots, namely
i and minus i.
And it's not possible
to tell which
is which. r1 is taking the
square root of minus 1,
and r2 is taking the
square root of minus 1.
One of them is adding the
The other one's subtracting
the square root of minus 1.
But which square
root of minus 1?
There's no way to tell
the difference between i
and minus i, abstractly.
They both behave the same way.
And so we have an ambiguity
about which one is r1
and which one is r2.
It doesn't hurt at
all for the theorem
that r1 and r2 are different.
And so there are two roots.
But ambiguity can
be problematic.
And let me give you an
illustration of that.
When there's ambiguity,
I can do things
like proving easily that
1 is equal to minus 1.
Here's the proof.
And I will let you contemplate
that and try to figure out just
where in this reasoning
that step by step
seems pretty reasonable,
but nevertheless I've
concluded that 1 is equal
to minus 1, which is absurd.
It's taking
advantage of the fact
that you don't know whether
the square root of minus 1
means i or minus i.
So the moral of all of
this is that, first of all,
be sure that you are
applying the rules properly.
There's an assumption of
an algebraic rule in there
that isn't true.
And again, that kind
of mindless calculation
is risky when you don't really
understand what you're doing,
you don't have a clear memory
of what the exact rules are.
So it's understanding
that bails you out
of this kind of blunder.
Let's look at 1 equals
minus 1 a little
because it lets us wrap
up with an amusing remark.
What's terrible about
1 equals minus 1?
Well, it's false, and you
don't want to ever conclude
something that's false.
That's worrisome.
It's disastrous
when you conclude
that something is false.
Let me give you an
illustration of why.
Because let's suppose the 1
is equal to minus 1 and let's
reason in a correct
from that assumption
that we have falsely proved.
But let's assume that we
start off with the assumption
that 1 is minus 1.
Well, if I multiply both
sides of an equation
by the same thing, it's equal.
So I can multiply
both sides by 1/2,
and I get 1/2 is
equal to minus 1/2.
Now I can also add the
same thing to both sides.
That's a perfectly sound move
for reasoning about equalities.
If I add 3/2 to both sides, I've
turn 1 equals minus 1 into 2
is equal to 1.
Now I'm in great shape to
prove all kinds of things.
Here's a famous one.
"Since I am the
Pope are clearly 2,
we conclude that I
and the Pope are one.
That is, I am the Pope."
And I've just proved to
you this absurd fact.
This is a joke
that's attributed--
a witty remark that's
attributed to Bertrand
Russell, the famous philosopher,
logician, pacifist, Nobel Prize
winner, who supposedly was
approached by some socialite
at a party who had heard
that mathematicians thought
that if 1 is equal to minus 1
then you could prove anything.
And so she challenged him,
prove that you're the Pope.
And supposedly Russell, who
was a notoriously quick wit,
came up with this example.
Who knows whether it's true.
It's a good story.
There's a picture
of the great man.
And you might care
to learn more about
this remarkable contributor
to logic, and philosophy,
and politics.